chaves you're here to talk about the
eSports it's an up-and-coming thing this
is it's great dear here because we
wanted to talk about ESPN any sports
everything and I was I reached at ESPN
we're gonna get them on I think maybe
later in a week I'm going to talk to
some of those folks I reached out to rod
of course he used to work here gamespot
as well and so we're gonna get those
guys in later in the week but you were
just so happen to be in town today so no
this was great i woke up and had a DM
from you asking if i could skype in and
i said well what why would I do that
when I'm right around the corner I could
just come and sit down so perfect yeah
so you're just fresh back from North
American LCS right yes yeah exactly so
down in LA for those that don't know I
do work at gamespot no but sometimes a
little little hidden away because I just
do the eSport stuff and I'm down in Los
Angeles too so I nothing that I've never
around the office here to to show up in
any other yeah once in a blue moose or
so but ya na LCS just kicked off this
this weekend and that's really exciting
and another big exciting thing that's
happening at least you know when it
comes to folks like us who are sort of
we're not we're not within the sort of
eSports community but we're very much
like interested in what's going on is
that is what's happening with ESPN it's
interesting a couple of weeks ago Bobby
Kotick was saying that when they bought
MLG they said were this is part of our
future plans to be the ESPN of eSports
and it turns out ESPN wants to also be
ESP enemies for its they've set up this
new section on their site they're sort
of they've been dabbling in any sports
before the course at the International
and while ago as well like from you
right from somebody who's been covering
eSports covering league legends for so
long what does this say to you that ESPN
are get involved I mean it's really
interesting I think for a long time
especially within the eSports community
there was a lot of desire for validation
because i think that the general
sentiment among the esports community
and fans and people working in is that
eSports are on par with traditional
sports you know physical athletic sports
and you know any time that ends up
happening or anytime that conversations
starts up sports fans and and even
prominent figures at ESPN and other
places have said
oh this is a joke you know like they
just talked about as a nerd thing and
whatever so I do think that there's a
great deal of validation for seeing them
come in and I I imagine it's only a sign
of things to come as as we start to see
kind of this this interesting Venn
diagram blur of you know game sites like
gamespot that cover eSports and then you
know if you see sports sites like ESPN
covering a sport eSports as well yeah so
there's a I guess his wind change has
been happening for years but even in
terms of months like I remember it was a
story in kotaku a couple of months ago
when yes being aired I think was like
hearts don't run when deciding on espn2
was like it was a heroes of the dorm the
heroes okay tournament yeah yeah and one
of them and this is a really great at
tweets about I can't believe ESPN's he
was showing nerds playing video games
says a self-confessed nerd who played a
place fantasy football my favorite one
is can we all just take a moment to
appreciate that the world of warcraft
championship is on espn2 yeah do you
think like this is like a big statement
then this is is this more representative
of people becoming okay with eSports
more or yes them looking for any non
something that's quite profitable I mean
it's a little bit of both right like I
don't think a company is going to be
interested in covering something that no
one's really interested in but I do
think that it also sort of shows that
people that are making those kind of
tweets quite frankly their opinion is
relevant whenever it comes to this
discussion because what what is actually
happening is you're seeing more and more
I mean BBC broadcast League of Legends
World Championships a couple months ago
ESPN is getting in like the sports sites
sports companies you know more and more
sponsors are coming in all of those
people are validating eSports as a sport
and so it doesn't really matter at the
end of the day like if a sports fan who
is only interested in watching MLB isn't
interested in eSports or does it feel
like it's a sport because the everybody
else is deciding that it is all the
people that are actually covering the
stuff all the people that are making
business deals around it you know do
think that so I don't have people to
watch it right exactly and I mean that
yeah that's the thing is that the
viewership is there and it's only
growing fans are more passionate fans
are getting more interest in the stuff
you know more and more stuff eSports are
coming along csgo
getting bigger and bigger every year Lee
continues to be a juggernaut like it's
just this is in my opinion that the
future and we're only going to see the
stuff it's going to be very funny to
look back on any of the splitted
journeys comments like 20 30 40 years
down the road when ever you know there's
just it's just commonly accepted yeah
okay let me let me know if you let me
digress and being self-indulgent for a
little second let me transport maybe
there's a couple of years I had further
into the future and I got to talk to
Peter about this a little bit if what
we're seeing is the mass media getting
into something like eSports which for a
long time was this sort of bubble right
we kind of feel the same way about video
games right when we were growing up it
was specialist magazine specialist price
there were some mainstream television
dabbling into it but for the most part
it was sort of off temperature and it
never really clicked right we don't have
a long series of television shows that
that sort of lasted the test of time
when it comes to games looking ahead say
like something like five years time if
something like eSports which is this
from super sort of like small passion of
a lot small sorry but like this like
very passionate community focused
community I'll say and is something that
ESPN are trying to get into do you think
maybe this is the the start of the
mainstream price you know in the way
we've seen mainstream culture really
latch onto games in the past two years
at try and sort of finally grab the
gaming audience did like do you see this
happening outside of eSports I think
it'll be easier for excuse me for
eSports content to be like easily
consumable and like to discover it the
one thing that I really wonder about is
whether ESPN is the right brand for
people who are already interested in
eSports because they are aligned with
things like football and baseball and so
while I don't think that ESPN will fail
what they're attempting I think what
they're going to do is provide a
foundation that other people will then
look use as an example to bolster up
maybe a more community focused like
eSport thing like I'm really from the
outside looking in but you know for me
like so many people who consume these
sports content their hate that I just
said consumed the people who did that
stuff you know don't worry we'll editor
that later yeah they do not which they
do it on YouTube right like they're
engaging with this stuff the way that
they have been and I don't know if
they're gonna then flock to ESPN but
again like you were saying I think it's
a good example of sort of the economy of
eSports being validated by these bigger
players that I think will then
my day a solid foundation it's still
hard to tell like you know when the
balance is going to tip in terms of
mainstream people wanting this because I
think they're even a lot of people like
our age and I don't know who is the
outlier and you know who's the exception
to this but not all of us like eSports
right but the younger generation they
really do so I think this might actually
provide a stronger like long-term gain
for things rather than the short term so
I can see it making it more mainstream
and more popular but I think ESPN is
gonna have maybe a rough time it's an
interesting question isn't it because
like if there is this big sort of clan
is ammar any sports and there's sort of
the well needed to be because like I
remember being super into counter-strike
and sort of being vaguely interested in
watching competitive games and when it
tried to break through and it kind of
did and then it like Peter that again
like the community in these lucky sport
games from my eyesight perspective they
seem to understand that if they want
this stuff to really work they need to
be passionate they need to give a [ __ ]
so when you see something like ESPN
getting a vault obviously like you're
saying it's a really good sort of marker
it's it's a great way of saying okay
we've been legitimized in this way but
do you think the eSports community cares
about ESPN's coverage like outright do
they care enough that they to watch it
because presumably if they're happy that
it exists if it crashes and burns that's
obviously not a very good you know
commentary on eSports either yeah i
think that the solution to that is to
hire people who people care about and
who already have a falling and that
seems to be what they're doing right and
full disclosure these guys are my
friends but you know people like fee on
who is a very prolific writer within the
League of Legends community and and
covers you know the eSports side of that
stuff it got picked up by them and he's
going to be putting features up and
already has several times and they've
reached out to eat like at the moment
that this was actually kind of an
interesting story the moment ESPN went
live with the site in the announcement
went out they only had I think it was
League dota and hearthstone up on the
top 10 I remember and people were you
know the csgo community kind of went
crazy about it that the smash community
like a lot because all the is ESPN
announcement went up on the boards for
all these different communities
everybody's reaction was like yeah
not covering our game or they're only
going to cover league and they did a
really good job of immediately being
like actually here's a really cool right
up on a smash tournament that's
happening this weekend nightly posts
that last week or an apparently they
have CS co content going up today so I
think they're doing a good job of being
really proactive in finding people that
are already creating content within
these communities and really helping to
spotlight them I think the other thing
and not to spend out off into too much
of a larger discussion but over it I
think that what's interesting to wonder
is what our ESPN long-term plans in the
eSports industry right as if is it just
like Oh words going to be these write
ups or are they looking to do more stuff
like they did with the heroes of the
dorm tournament where they're going to
broadcast it on espn2 are they looking
to you know they the we're seeing a lot
of these companies move into streaming
traditional sports on their sites and
doing stuff like that are they going to
become a twitch competitor whenever it
comes to rice a lot of these tournaments
so and in it if that's the case and
there you know ESPN starts broadcasting
a league of legends tournament or a
hearthstone tournament or whatever and
then they're also having coverage on
their site with really prolific folks
from from that community I keep using
prolific my new favorite word you know
then then we're going to start to see I
think that brand become much more
accepted and and well known within the
industry yeah I guess last question is
it's sort of like a personal one that I
want to ask you I touch them a bit
earlier like you were at an ALCS last
week you've been covering this stuff for
years and years and years and we were
talking before the show you were saying
about how it used to be like you turn up
to these events and like maybe who
another youtuber and now you turn up in
sports center and ESPN and everyone's
there and do you think this has been a
long time coming or like are you are you
shocked in 2016 the DSBN have done this
or does it now feel like right yeah I
think I think now's a good time I think
that the growth has been very
significant over the past years for this
but yet it definitely would have been a
very strange thing for me to see at the
start of LCS you know three or so years
ago
and now with all the changes I've been
seeing you know Rick Fox former NBA
lakers champion is owns a team and a
nail I saw the ring is that where you
had to ring up there was a ring I don't
want to say where I got it but yes I was
the first and probably only time I'll
have something worth four hundred
thousand dollars on my finger orange it
hasn't died that was what I was an uh
and so yeah I like that stuff is just
happening and especially in 2015 we saw
more and more of this so it definitely
it feels like it you know this is just
the next step yeah travis carver thank
you so much for coming in great avianna
lobby finally thank you it's been good
to be here yeah do some content with you
now I'm going to just get up an extra
risk we're not doin a trailer so you
just take your cans off and walk and
hopefully there's a there's a short guy
with less hair than you think I was
gonna come in and talk about different
video hopefully ok I'll look for a mo
very nice coming right in thanks so much
appreciate it to you